this video is sponsored by zest
t okay so it looks like you are going to
be with us for
a little while that's no problem we are
just going to draw a little blood and
then we'll get you fitted for a
nice straight jacket
[Music]
yes it's that time of year
but i thought in lieu of reviewing some
scary movie or a tv show instead
i'd rather talk about a staple of the
horror movie genre
the asylum where the mad
are sent to scream from with inside
padded cells there are howls
echoing down dimly lit halls
yeah except have you ever stopped to
think about
how messed up that is
that's right it's time to talk about
another trope that has some
rather nasty baggage behind it and today
we're going to be talking about
depictions of mental health facilities
and mental health care professionals in
popular culture
because if i were to tell you that a
film or a tv show took place in an
asylum
or had a character being committed to
one
what are you more likely to picture in
your head
this or this
are you more likely to assume it's a
story about recovery
or a story about succumbing to madness
if a character
gets committed are you going to think oh
i hope they get the help they need or
are you going to think
oh no
i'm pretty confident in saying it was
the latter case
for most if not all of you on all those
instances
and most of us can thank at least in
part the
pop culture depiction of mental health
facilities and professionals
for that perspective now some people may
well have their opinion of mental health
facilities
shaped by personal experience but for
the rest of us
because despite what some folks may
think i've only ever been diagnosed with
adhd and nothing more severe than that
we as an audience are going to cue off
the depictions provided to us
by the entertainment that we consume and
that is
overwhelmingly negative now
as with every trope i talk about this is
not meant to be a condemnation of any
particular piece of work
and i am going to cite more than a few
films that i actually
genuinely like but i'm going to cite
them for negative depictions
but as with any trope the issue is in
the overuse the problem is the pattern
because
it becomes the default that shapes our
thoughts and our feelings about
something
and this is something that is very real
and many of us lack first-hand knowledge
of it
and i'm also not going to pretend that
the horrifying
asylum archetype doesn't have some basis
in reality there have been
many points in history where mental
health practices were at best misguided
and at worst
actual atrocities and such things can
still happen even now but
that's also true of traditional medicine
but you don't see every depiction of a
hospital as a rundown hell hole
filled with sadistic doctors and in
different nurses
i'm going to be getting into a whole
bunch of examples but
stick around even after i show you the
receipts on this because
we're going to have to talk about the
potential hazards
of these depictions being so common
now as i get into these i'm going to be
focusing primarily on
mental health facilities and also some
citations of
specific professionals such as
therapists or psychiatrists
there's a couple of things that i won't
be including at least not
directly things like substance abuse
rehab and group
therapy except for where they overlap
with more generalized mental health
facilities
the reasons for this is that it's
actually fairly common to get single
scenes of something like group therapy
in a film otherwise
not about it and drug rehab really does
get treated different from general
mental health
and accordingly the societal attitudes
towards each
is a bit different so that felt like
money in the waters to lump that in
additionally i'm trying to focus this on
the depiction of mental health
professionals
not on people with mental health
conditions
that is honestly its own can of worms
and one that
we should all be aware of i just i don't
have the space
to do it justice here
[Music]
coming up with negative examples was
preposterously easy
even sticking to mainstream
entertainment and avoiding the mountain
of dirt cheap direct-to-streaming horror
movies set in asylums
for the most part i found that most
negative depictions sorted into
one of three categories facilities that
gaslight their patients
facilities that are basically a prison
for specific kinds of bad people
and facilities that are just flat out
nightmarish hell holes
now since i already mentioned it i
should define the term gaslighting it
refers to the
mental and emotionally abusive practice
of making a person doubt their memory
cognitive ability or sanity so in that
vein we have films like
sucker punch or glass where it is to the
advantage of the characters running the
facility to make the patients doubt
their own perceptions in the same line
of thinking we have terminator 2 which
took
the fairly reasonable psychiatrist
character from the first film
and had him lock up sarah connor and
make it his mission to convince her that
she was delusional when she was
not there's also the film the changeling
based on real life events
where an entire police department
conspired to gaslight a woman whose son
has been kidnapped
into believing that they had found him
when in fact the child they brought to
her
was not her son and they were fully
aware of that
under the asylums are just a special
kind of prison
depiction we've got the halloween
franchise silence of the lambs
that one comes complete with a
self-serving head psychiatrist for
bonus points punisher war zone and
literally
anything involving arkham asylum for the
batman mythos
we pretty much never see these
facilities depicted as places of
treatment or of medicine it's just where
we house the crazy bad people
and then for the utter hell holds we've
got the likes of 12 monkeys
shutter island and oh hey look it's
arkham again
american horror story's second season
fittingly titled asylum manages to be
all of these things and is also my
favorite season of the show go figure
there are also a handful of problematic
outliers that don't fit cleanly into the
other
categories but are worth mentioning like
say patch adams
where the workers in a mental health
facility that the titular character is
in at the front end of the film
aren't evil or uncaring but are clearly
incompetent and very unhelpful
there's garden state which treats going
off your meds like the world's most
cathartic
and freeing experience or there's the
recent joker which has healthcare
workers so
ground down by a system that isn't
working they seem to be doing a little
more than
punching their time clocks day in and
day out
now there are some depictions that
aren't as
holy negative as the ones that i've been
listening so far
but at the end of the day still paint a
overall kind of dim
view one of the archetypical examples
falls under this more mixed heading i'm
speaking of one
flew over the cuckoo's nest this classic
jack nicholson film
based on the novel of the same name
features a facility that
is not shown to be miserable from the
word go
but by the end it's definitely not a
place you're going to have a positive
view about even though
much of the trouble that is caused is
stirred up at least initially by
nicholson's
character of mcmurphy between the
spiteful nurse ratchet
and the willingness of doctors to render
a troublesome patient
comatose this is not shown to be a place
of helping or of healing
girl interrupted falls under a bit of a
similar heading
angelina jolie's character is ultimately
the source of much of the trouble but
the facility isn't shown to be
particularly effective
and the safety precautions are
disturbingly lacks with how often these
people are running a muck
there's the tv show house which had the
titular character
check himself into a facility for both
drug rehab and
mental health issues and while
it doesn't appear to be an outright
terrible place and some value
is placed on what's being done there we
still have the lacks safety measures
issue
combined with house whose medical
training is in
physical health not mental still having
better luck
diagnosing and assisting at least one
other patient than the actual mental
health professionals
there's a beautiful mind which does
acknowledge the lead characters need to
confront
the mental issues he's been ignoring but
in the end the solution isn't medication
or even therapy it's
deciding to not believe his delusions
anymore i feel like a lot of comedic
portrayals of mental health
professionals fall into this more
mixed category as well whether it be
something like
analyze this or more woody allen movies
than i would care to count and also
won't watch anyways because ew
one can argue that there's an attempt to
normalize therapy and things like this
but
it's still ultimately being presented as
a source of laughter something to
mock and take amusement from even my
favorite broadway musical
next to normal has a mixed depiction at
best while i'll praise that show for its
examination of the impact of mental
illness on a family and it's
brilliant ending that manages to be both
somber and
uplifting ultimately the treatments and
medications given to the character of
diana are ineffectual in the end and i
don't believe it to be the intended
message of
the show i still would find it
understandable if some people came away
after seeing that play thinking oh yeah
mental illness caused a lot of problems
but i mean
none of the drugs or treatments helped
so what good did any of that
do
[Music]
so what is the cumulative effect of all
this
well i would be far from the first
person to point out that on the whole
our society in this country has a
fundamentally different view of mental
health than it does of physical health
while people with physical health
problems are
sadly often left to struggle in ways
that shouldn't happen
in a civilized society only the
sketchiest
of edgelords would tell somebody
confined to a wheelchair that it's all
in their heads
and that they're weak if they need help
mental health though
in america at least mental health
concerns carry a very heavy stigma and
seeking help
with them seems to largely play into
that stigma rather than alleviate it
by and large the cultural attitude
towards professional help or medication
for mental health issues is that they
placate numb or zombify the person so
they don't have to deal with their
problems rather than being seen as an
actual way to address those issues
someone with a broken leg who has a cast
on isn't shamed as weak or somehow
a failure for needing that help
but then that might also speak
to part of the disconnect when it comes
to matters of physical health
there is often at least a potential
for a full recovery the image most
able-bodied people
have a physical health is that something
went wrong
you get treated it gets better you're
back to normal
now there are of course chronic physical
conditions which
break this narrative but the thing is
virtually
every mental health condition breaks
that narrative
a mental health condition be it ptsd
adhd
autism depression tourette's or anything
else is not something that is ever going
to be
cured in the way that people think of
physical health it can be
managed but it won't ever just go away
that isn't how it works and i think that
honestly scares a lot of people
the idea that some pains some health
issues won't ever be truly
fixed and i put air quotes on that for a
reason because
some of us with some of these conditions
don't think there's actually anything
wrong with us we just process
differently from the rest of you
and while i would never claim
that the depiction of mental health
facilities and workers as either evil
or ineffectual is somehow the root cause
of this overall
cultural perception it does definitely
play into it
and reinforce it so much like every kind
of representation i talk about
if you don't have real life experience
with this kind of thing then
you tend to lean on the pop culture
depiction of it and if
the most common depiction is this
negative
that's more than a little concerning
but i get to bring it back to a more
uplifting note
because there are depictions of mental
health
and mental health professionals that i
can comfortably label
as positive not nearly as many as i
would like
and i hope folks will drop even more
down in the comments
but they are certainly out there there's
robin williams's
sean mcguire in good will hunting who
was able to reach
an angry young man who has never had
support for his emotional
and mental health in the way that
williams is able to provide
there's the sopranos and the character
of jennifer melfi
played by lorraine bronco while not an
idealized portrayal that can be chalked
up to her being a flawed human character
but the actual work that she does with
tony is largely shown to be
necessary and is respectful of the
therapeutic process
and then there's the show that i really
want to talk about
crazy ex-girlfriend if you've never seen
it crazy ex-girlfriend
is a musical comedic drama created by
and starring
rachel bloom an extremely talented
actress that i
was in a movie with once yet don't be
that impressed the movie never got a
release and she'd have
no reason to remember me but anyways
crazy ex-girlfriend follows the
character of rebecca bunch
an up-and-coming lawyer in a new york
city law firm who is
deeply unhappy with her life
a chance meeting with her crush from
summer camp back in her teen years
prompts her to quit her job and move
across the country to west covina
california
in the hope of rekindling that romance
four seasons of musical shenanigans
ensue but
here's the thing i want to focus on and
this
is going to involve some later season
spoilers
the show is still well worth your time
even knowing the things i'm about to
tell you
the impulsive and destructive choices
that rebecca makes
throughout the show are frequently
played for comedy
but the show also recognizes that these
come from somewhere
rebecca isn't wacky she's hurting
she's traumatized and she's very bad at
recognizing how poorly she copes with
any of that
this culminates in rebecca's suicide
attempt halfway through the third season
this is the point at which she finally
tries to
seriously engage with her mental health
she's had a therapist since the first
season but she never did the work
which is really key to this depiction
because it's true that while her therapy
doesn't really seem to be helping for a
long time it's also very clear that
rebecca's situation is not a failure of
the medicine
it's her own continued failure to
actually
do what's being asked of her and to
follow the advice she's being given
even as she eventually sees other
doctors attends both individual and
group therapies and continues to
struggle
it's never framed as the mental health
tools she's
offered being ineffectual and the show
spends a full
season and a half dealing with the
repercussions of her
actions and how much work she has to put
in
so that she can start to address her
issues
the show even tackles things like
backsliding without acting like it means
that her treatments failed
it is an amazing portrayal of mental
illness and more importantly to this
video
the professionals who try to help people
with it to the point of being praised by
psychology today
and on top of that it has hilarious
songs an awesomely diverse cast
fantastic lgbtq plus representation and
look this show is really really good and
if you haven't seen it i can't recommend
it enough
now a show like crazy ex-girlfriend not
only being made but
doing well and being praised for its
work feels like a step in the right
direction
of depicting mental health and mental
health professionals
in a more positive light but
it's also just one show
i deeply desperately hope that this is
the start of a trend and not a one-off
because
when we think about our loved ones or
ourselves seeking
mental health treatment our first
thoughts should not
include straight jackets padded rooms
and electroshock
that's not to say we couldn't all use a
jolt from time to time which brings us
to the sponsor's video
wait really we're really
going with that
[Music]
electroshock to caffeinated tea okay
zest tea offers a variety of products
from canned sparkling teas to more
traditional
bagged or loose leaf teas and even cbd
products with more caffeine than a cup
of coffee it's a way for tea drinkers to
get the energy
they need all products are available for
either a one-off purchase
or you can also subscribe for regular
deliveries and
be sure that you will never be short of
what you need
and if you use the link below and the
coupon code
nathaniel yes that is my name if you've
never watched the credits
if you use that you can get free
shipping on your first purchase
so that wraps up this one
depiction of mental health facilities
and professionals
what do you think about this what
examples would you offer of
positive depictions of mental health
workers and
if you've seen crazy ex-girlfriend
what's your favorite song from it
i'll always have a soft spot for the
sexy getting ready song but
i think i'd have to give the top spot to
you stupid [ __ ] that one's so epic
whatever your thoughts are drop them
down in the comments let's talk about it
and in addition today's sponsor this
channel is
as always supported by patreon there's
the thing
that keeps me fed and all the usual like
share subscribe
etc but i can't tell you what to do
because at the end of the day you're the
council i
am just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned be safe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]